nous pardon Isabelle mourir ah non
Isabelle
c'est compliqué
j'aime autant Isabelle que karena c'est
compliqué pour moi c'est un peu
schizophrénique mais effectivement elle
voulait quand même journaliste et star
en fait non mais ça a été une évolution
sur quelques décennies pas de quand même
quand même avec avec tous ces tubes là
la chanson c'est fini mais c'est fini
depuis 30 ans mais oui mais bon
je sais bien alors regarde un petit
récap de votre vie non carrément ouais
carrément et puis derrière vous répondez
à toutes les questions regardez
du Top 50 dans les années 70 et 80 vous
l'avez découvert tout le nom de Karen
Cheryl c'est avec son premier titre
garde-moi avec toi qu'elle va se faire
remarquer du grand public
[Musique]
mais son succès Karen va le connaître en
1978 après un séjour à New York
changement de look et surtout d'univers
la chanteuse va se tourner vers un stick
beaucoup plus disco avec deux tubes
chomillions
[Musique]
qui deviendra disque d'or
mais la chanteuse se trouve aussi des
talents de comédienne en jouant dans
plusieurs sitcoms comme les nouvelles
filles d'à côté
dans du thé citron sans sucre au début
des années 2000 Karen va se consacrer à
sa vraie passion le journalisme en
abandonnant son nom de scène pour
redevenir Isabelle Morizet tu as décidé
de renoncer définitivement la chanson
bonne chance Isabelle alors une carrière
à la radio sur Europe 1 une maison
qu'elle n'a jamais vraiment quitté
jusqu'à aujourd'hui est-ce que le succès
ça guérit ça ne guérit de rien du tout
la ligne désormais tous les samedis et
dimanche l'émission il n'y a pas qu'une
vie dans la vie un tête-à-tête d'une
heure avec diverses personnalités mais
ce soir c'est elle notre invité
exceptionnelle dans TPMP people
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et avec cette zone incroyable on a tous
vu l'archive mais elle est un peu cher
pour nous effectivement il veut une
chanson c'était à l'envers à l'endroit
et Jean-Pierre Foucault
alors mais quel courage quand même
d'abord de réussir autant dire que j'ai
fait tout ça non mais surtout pourquoi
tout d'un coup parce qu'il y a très peu
de personnes qui arrêtent quand ils sont
au top on voit pas la descente arriver
et vous vous avez arrêté 30 millions de
disques vendus pourquoi vous arrêtez
c'est en fait une question d'amour
propre voilà je ne voulais pas devenir
une chanteuse une compilation ça a été
très joyeux j'ai rendu 27 millions
disques grâce au public c'est vrai j'ai
voyagé partout ça a été vraiment
prodigieux mais je vous laisse savoir si
j'étais capable de ré-escalader la
colline autrement donc voilà j'ai décidé
je vous l'avoue c'est plutôt courageuse
de sauter du train en marche pour me
lancer vers une aventure improbable je
ne savais absolument pas si ça allait
marcher je n'étais pas légitime je
venais de la chanson je rêvais de
recevoir des personnalités de tout
milieu et effectivement
voilà radio depuis 24 ans et dans un
milieu d'hommes vraiment je pense que
vous attendez pas mais j'ai reçu j'ai
reçu des personnalités qui vont de
Simone Veil à Jean Charpak prix Nobel de
physique agent d'urbation en passant par
Vanessa Paradis ou traitement il y en a
plusieurs fusée au début quand vous on
vous dites évidemment au début ils ont
refusé et ce que je trouve assez
savoureux c'est que finalement pas très
longtemps après les agents les attachés
de presse se passaient un petit coup de
fil en disant se rendre compte que
l'émission marchait bien et puis surtout
que j'essayais d'y mettre du fond parce
que
pas hésité est un vilain défaut mais
c'est aussi mon carburant et je
m'intéresse vraiment aux gens je
travaille seul et cette émission elle
dure une heure c'est un entretient que
j'essaye de préparer un petit peu comme
une pièce de théâtre il y a des pépites
que je répartis comme ça et vous pensez
que maintenant on connaît mieux Isabelle
Morizet
on ne connaît pas Isabelle ça prend du
temps
on a invité Michel Onfray aussi
en fait les journalistes sont assez
paresseux ça c'est vrai maintenant
c'est à dire que c'est vrai en fait
quand sera un article très souvent ce
sont les reprises bien sûr de choses
exumées il y a des années qui déjà au
départ étaient fausses sont reprises
par exemple pratiquement tout mais non
mais si oui
pour une mythomane c'est pas grave moi
je sais que je l'ai vécu moi je suis ici
parce que je trouve l'émission
sympathique je suis venu simplement pour
passer un moment festif avec vous je
n'ai rien à prouver rien à légitimer
rien n'avant c'était à l'époque disco
c'était deux mois avant qu'il ne sortent
l'album Thriller
donc il est venu me voir en me disant on
répétait un show en live il avait repéré
la petite frenchy à queue de cheval avec
ses danseurs il y a les j'aimerais bien
qu'on fasse le final ensemble sur un
titre d'album donc bien évidemment j'ai
accepté de chanter en duo avec Bambi la
star déjà le premier disque que j'ai
acheté quand j'avais 9 ans c'était NBC
et
Village People chic faisait les cœurs
avec les premières lumars c'était dans
un décor absolument surréaliste
hallucinant tout ça et gravé dans ma
mémoire il n'y a pas d'image il était
comment lui nage il était comment il en
fait il était une délicatesse inouïe
avec une voix de jeunes filles il était
d'une douceur il voyait absolument tout
il plaçait les caméras bien sûr pilotait
tout comme s'il était et vous m'avez en
plus incroyable vous m'avez dit et
c'était avant la dépigmentation de la
politique est encore noir en fait voilà
sa peau n'était pas encore blanc et
il s'était désolée donc des Jackson Five
thriller qui allait être l'album
planétaire n'était pas encore sorti
c'était une période de latence et
c'était un moment en fait j'étais en
apnée et il paraît aussi
pardon
est-ce que l'on va faire
non il y a rien
mais non
vous êtes très jolie vous l'étiez aussi
déjà très joli parce que non
très bien mais vous pouvez vous savez
aussi vous avez aussi été rencontré
Claude François alors là oui on a les
images effectivement
on a des photos
de la radio SNC c'est vrai salut les
copains salut les copains non mais
Claude François on avait un projet juste
avant qu'il ne disparaisse parce que moi
j'ai appris à jouer de la batterie on
m'a remis un premier prix execo de
batterie là on nous voit tous les deux
émissions qui en plus c'était diffusé en
Eurovision et on avait préparé pour un
chaud écarpentiers qui devait se tourner
10 jours après sa disparition elle s'en
avait préparé donc dans ces bureaux qui
étaient chez flèches à Paris chacun
caché derrière sa batterie un donc un
solo en afro-cubain et puis et puis j'ai
appris soudain voilà la France s'est
arrêté de respirer
l'annonce est tombée il était
pas ça non mais parce que enfin isabelle
a pas couché
d’être venu non mais non
vous êtes encore très jeune mais il y a
plusieurs générations alors je suis pas
du tout
mais pour moi c'était les filles d'à
côté il y avait les filles d'accord
c'est un excellent souvenir parce que
par exemple Marie chevalier est resté
une amie mais en même temps j'avais une
vie parallèle c'est-à-dire que mon petit
cartable rouge j'allais présenter des
projets dans diverses chaînes de télé en
radio parce que je pensais déjà à
l'avenir donc je tournais l'après-midi
et puis le matin j'avais des rendez-vous
voilà avec des producteurs
parce que j'avais envie d'expérimenter
autre chose et puis il faut toujours
vous savez
s'éclipser avant que
c'est votre panier alors à propos de
succès on me souffle éventuellement tF1
aurait ou penserez à vous pour danse
avec retard ça c'est un truc que je suis
sûr que vous diriez oui alors vous êtes
plus au courant que moi parce que vous
diriez oui
avec ça vous avez une panique d'arrêter
vous enfin mais non mais vous diriez oui
je regarde l'émission et ils sont très
très bluffants comme je regarde chaque
fois de Voice on a des talents
absolument incroyable en France ils
n'ont aucun trac ils ont une maîtrise et
surtout un groove quand ils interprètent
des titres de Beyoncé maintenant ça
prend vraiment le Canada ils vont votre
est-ce que vous regardez la star oui
bien sûr parfait j'ai besoin de votre
avis est-ce que pour rester avec nous
pour la Star Ac chiche